do you think we'll one day build a net
AI system that a human being can love
and that loves that human back like in
the movie her look I'm I'm a pragmatist
for me AI is a is a tool it's like a
shovel and the ethics of using the
shovel I always with us the people and
and it has to be this way in terms of
emotions I would hate to come into my
kitchen and see that my refrigerator
spoiled all my food then have it
explained to me that it fell in love
with the dishwasher and I wasn't as nice
the dishwasher so as a result it
neglected me there would just be a bad
experience and it would be a bad product
I would probably not recommend this for
frigerator to my friends and that's
where I draw the line I think to me
technology has to be reliable it has to
be predictable I want my car to work I
don't want to fall in love with my car I
just wanted to work I wanted to
compliment me not to replace me
I have very unique human properties and
I want the machines to make me turn me
into a superhuman like I'm already a
superhuman today thanks to the machines
that surround me and give you examples I
can run across the Atlantic at near the
speed of sound at 36,000 feet today
that's kind of amazing I can my voice
now carries me all the way to Australia
using a smartphone today and it's not
not the speed of sound which would take
hours it's the speed of light my voice
travels at the speed of light how cool
is that that makes me superhuman I would
even argue my my flushing toilet makes
me superhuman just think of the time
before flushing toilets and and maybe
you have a veiled person in your family
that you can ask about this or take a
trip to rural India and to experience it
it's it's it makes me superhuman so to
me what technology does it complements
me it makes me stronger
therefore words like love and compassion
have very little
a very little interest in these four
machines I have interested in people you
don't think first of all beautifully put
beautifully argued but do you think love
has use in our tools compassion
I think laughs is a beautiful human
concept and if you think what love
really is love is a means to convey
safety to convey trust I think Trust has
a huge need in technology as well much
as people we want to trust our
technology the same agree to a similar
way we trust people in in human
interaction standards have emerged and
and feelings emotions have emerged may
be genetically may be very largely that
I able to convey sense of trust sense of
safety sense of passion of love of
dedication that that makes the human
fabric and I'm a big slacker for love I
want to be laughed I want to be trusted
ever be admired all these wonderful
things and because all of us for who we
have this beautiful system I wouldn't
just blindly copy this to the machines
he is why when you look at say
transportation
you could have observed that up to the
end of the 19th century almost all
transportation used any number of legs
from one leg to two legs to a thousand
legs and you could have concluded that
is the right way to move about the
environment we've been reading session
of birds who is flapping wings in fact
there are many people in aviation that
flap wings to their arms and jump from
Cliffs most of them didn't survive then
then the interesting thing is that the
technology solutions are very different
like in technologies really easily by
the wheel in biology is super hard to
build a wheel that's very few
perpetually rotating things in in in
biology and they even sell things in
engineering we can build wheels and
those wheels gave rise to cars similar
wheels gave rides to to aviation like
there's no thing that flies they
wouldn't have something rotates like a
jet
helicopter blades so the solutions have
used very different physical laws in
nature and that's great so for me to be
too much focused on oh this is how
nature does it lets us replicated if we
really believed that the solution to the
agriculture evolution was a humanoid
robot it would still be waiting today
you